he said we got the test results back and
your your gut looks fine mm-hmm but they
did find a tumor
apologies he said that they did find a
tumor on my right kidney
[Music]
it's funny I told the story so many
times but the tough part is kind of
going back there mentally and
remembering with definitely anyway he
had said that there was a tumor on the
kid of course they couldn't say at that
time a hard percent that it was renal
cell carcinoma I said like what does
that I didn't even yeah everyone cell
carcinomas that means hey is that kidney
cancer they said yes when you get that
information you either go into shock or
you are scared to share that information
with loved ones sometimes we want to
keep it to yourself so if you don't have
to deal with that did you hesitate in
any way to call Vanessa so I didn't
hesitate at all to call - I called her
immediately it felt like time Stood
Still
you know when you'd hear you know your
husband or your wife you know found you
know tumor in their body it's yeah that
moment just doesn't seem real and you
must have said something really positive
to him we're gonna fight this we're
gonna be great but what were you going
through at that moment I mean massive
fear yeah
[Music]
but yeah I wanted to be the strong one
and I I did you know I think I did say
something right away right away you know
positive and mm-hmm whatever it was you
know we're we're gonna do it together
meant
you know you don't start crying because
we're gonna start read those couple of
days of not really knowing what the
prognosis was it felt like weeks yeah
definitely weeks so you have a plan in
place at this point and the kids don't
know no I don't know okay so you're not
to tell your kids how did that happen
you tell them individually do you talk
to them in the kitchen how did how did
that happen
we're right here yeah how do you react
lalla got very emotional yeah
Lukas just got really quiet there was a
lot of quiet it was very quiet in the
room you just got that fear you're going
in you're being knocked out listen you
know I think it was under for five hours
searcher is about three three and a half
and that's a long time you never know
Cameron underwent the highly specialized
procedure in September to remove a tumor
roughly the size of a golf ball along
with part of his kidney his two children
recall what it was like to see their dad
come out of surgery how did you feel
that day I guess I'd never seen him like
so vulnerable before and it was really
cause he's always been like my hero kind
of and it was just like she kind of got
beaten down but then after he recovered
it was kind of like he was even stronger
after that and he was more of my hero
and it was really it was really great to
see now your dad was telling you he was
like not giving you the all the
information was downplaying it although
did that bother you a little bit I mean
I guess I just went to the worst-case
scenario I was saying that I felt like I
was trying to put on a good face through
my recovery and everything and meanwhile
I I sort of learned over time that
really you guys were putting on a good
face for me seeing you at the first day
after the surgery was pretty pretty
weird
because you're so like out of it you're
way more out of it I thought you would
be and it took some getting used to but
I know you're gonna be okay has it
changed you now I feel like this is kind
of my you know the first phase of this
new part of my life kind of thing a
second chance kind of sense and I try to
remember how fragile life is every day
you know what I mean like good basically
you just never know and that's very
inspiring for me to make the most of it
to be present to be kind to be helpful
to try and use the story to benefit
others as far as being your best
advocate for your own health and
obviously just steal every moment I can
with my kids and friends and family yeah
[Music]